>> Ed: THANKS FOR STARTING US
OFF.
>> Sandra: ALL RIGHT, PRESIDENT
TRUMP MEANWHILE UNVEILING A NEW
RAPID TEST KIT FOR CORONAVIRUS
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO GIVE
RESULTS WITHIN FIVE MINUTES OF
TAKING IT.
YESTERDAY’S ANNOUNCEMENT COMING
DAYS AFTER A MANUFACTURER
ABBOTT LABS SAID THE FDA HAD
GIVEN THEM EMERGENCY CLEARANCE
TO PRODUCE ITS CARTRIDGE-BASED
TEST.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS JOINING US LIVE
WITH MORE ON THAT.
JOHN, GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
THE PRESIDENT VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THIS NEW RAPID
FIVE-MINUTE TEST FROM ABBOTT
LABS DISPLAYING IT IN THE ROSE
GARDEN OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE EXPECT TO GET MORE DETAILS
ON WHAT THE NEW GUIDELINES
REGARDING SOCIAL DISTANCING
WILL BE.
THEY WILL BE IN PLACE UNTIL
APRIL 30th.
THE DATA BEHIND THOSE.
THE DAILY CORONAVIRUS BRIEFING
IN THE ROSE GARDEN YESTERDAY
THE PRESIDENT INDICATING HE
RECEIVED A STARTLING FORECAST
FROM HIS MEDICAL TEAM ABOUT
WHAT COULD HAPPEN IF THOSE
GUIDELINES WERE RELAXED TOO
EARLY.
I ASKED THE PRESIDENT WHETHER
THE GUIDELINES WOULD BE THE
SAME OR IF THEY WOULD BE
MODIFIED.
LISTEN HERE.
>> President Trump: WE MAY ADD
A FEW MORE BUT THE GUIDELINES
WILL BE VERY MUCH AS THEY ARE.
MAYBE EVEN TOUGHENED UP A
LITTLE BIT.
THEY’RE HAVING A BIG IMPACT.
THIS IS BASED ON MODELING THAT
SHOWS THE PEAK IN FATALITIES
WILL NOT ARRIVE FOR ANOTHER TWO
WEEKS.
THE SAME MODELING ALSO SHOWS
THAT BY VERY VIGOROUSLY
FOLLOWING THESE GUIDELINES WE
COULD SAVE MORE THAN ONE
MILLION AMERICAN LIVES.
>> BORDER RESTRICTIONS WILL
STAY IN PLACE.
TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS FROM THE
E.U. ARE UP FOR RECONSIDERATION
APRIL 13th.
TRAVEL RESTRIKE TUNS ACROSS THE
U.S. AND MEXICO AND CANADA
BORDERS UP FOR RENEWAL.
THE PRESIDENT SUGGESTED THERE
WOULDN’T BE A CHANGE THERE.
THE WHITE HOUSE CONTINUES TO
WORK WITH PRIVATE CORPORATIONS
TO RAMP UP AND DELIVER
DESPERATELY NEEDED MEDICAL
SUPPLIES.
THE PRESIDENT ANNOUNCING THAT
DRUG COMPANIES WILL BE MAKING
AVAILABLE SOME 17 MILLION DOSES
OF CHLOROQUINE TO TREAT
PATIENTS AND ANNOUNCING FORD
MOTORS HAS PARTNERED WITH
GENERAL ELECTRIC TO PRODUCE
50,000 VENTILATORS IN THE NEXT
100 DAYS.
I ASKED THE PRESIDENT ABOUT
THAT, TOO.
LISTEN HERE.
>> President Trump: SO WE HAVE
NOW 10 COMPANIES AT LEAST
MAKING THE VENTILATORS.
AND WE SAY GO AHEAD.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE AS WE
APPROACH THIS PEAK IN A COUPLE
OF WEEKS THERE WILL BE ENOUGH
FOR THE AMERICAN POPULATION?
>> President Trump: I DO THINK
SO, YES.
I DO THINK SO.
I THINK WE’LL BE IN VERY GOOD
SHAPE.
>> MORE INFORMATION FROM THE
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE ON HOW
LONG WE WILL BE DEALING WITH
THIS VIRUS.
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI SAYING HE
EXPECTS THAT, LIKE THE FLU,
CORONAVIRUS WILL COME BACK
AGAIN IN THE FALL BUT THAT IT
WILL BE A VERY DIFFERENT
SITUATION.
LISTEN HERE.
>> I WOULD ANTICIPATE THAT THAT
WOULD ACTUALLY HAPPEN BECAUSE
OF THE DEGREE OF TRANCE
MISSABILITY.
HOWEVER, IF YOU COME BACK IN
THE FALL IT WILL BE A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT BALLGAME OF WHAT
HAPPENED WHEN WE FIRST GOT HIT
WITH IT IN THE BEGINNING OF
THIS YEAR.
THERE WILL BE SEVERAL THINGS
THAT WILL BE DIFFERENT.
OUR ABILITY TO GO OUT AND BE
ABLE TO TEST, IDENTIFY, ISOLATE
AND CONTACT TRACE WILL BE
ORDERS OF MAGNITUDE BETTER THAN
WHAT IT WAS JUST A COUPLE OF
MONTHS AGO.
IT WILL BE THINGS WE HAVE
AVAILABLE TO US THAT WE DID NOT
HAVE BEFORE.
>> ONE OF THOSE THINGS
HOPEFULLY WILL BE A VACCINE AS
WELL.
THE PRESIDENT IN THE ROSE
GARDEN HAD WITH HIM THE CEOs OF
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT COMPANIES
PITCHING IN TO HELP OUT WHEN IT
COMES TO PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT, THE CEO OF UNITED
TECHNOLOGY SAYING HIS COMPANY
WILL BE MAKING AVAILABLE
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT.
HE HAS IN ITS STOCKPILES AS
WELL AND MAKING FACEMASKS AS
WELL.
HE DOESN’T NEED THE DEFENSE
PRODUCTION ACT TO GET HIS
COMPANY TO MOVE.
THE PRESIDENT WILL HAVE A
TELECONFERENCE THIS AFTERNOON
WITH NETWORK SERVICE PROVIDERS
AND AT 5:00 WE’LL HAVE THE
DAILY CORONAVIRUS BRIEFING AND
SEE WHAT THAT BRINGS LATER ON
TODAY.
>> Sandra: THANK YOU FOR YOUR